بدأت الرقص في سن صغيرة جدًا وتطور الأمر
إلى شغف وحب عندما كبرت
وانخرطت في ثقافة الهيب هوب لأنني
نشأت حول الهيب هوب [
الموسيقى]
لم نكن نسمع الكثير من
النساء المسلمات ولكننا  كنا نسمع الكثير
عن النساء المسلمات في وسائل الإعلام الغربية
وكنت أتسوق في متجر
يرتاده الكثير من النساء المسلمات وسمعت
هذه المرأة التي تعمل في
المتجر
تقول لقد سئمت من رؤية كل هؤلاء
النساء المحجبات
وكان الأمر مزعجًا حقًا  أنا
لذلك قمت بإنشاء مقطوعة حيث كنت أنا
وراقصاتي في ذلك الوقت إيمان وخديجة نرتدي
أه العباءة وكنا أيضًا
نرتدي النقاب لذلك أردت أن أجعلنا
مثل فتيات الهيب هوب الخارقات وقد
تأثر بها الكثير من الناس
ولذا فإن عملي يركز حقًا على الوحدة
وأيضًا مكافحة الإسلاموفوبيا وخطاب الكراهية
[الموسيقى]
في العامين الماضيين، لقد كنت
أصنع أفلامًا راقصة وأغوص
في نوع جديد جدًا لنفسي بصرف النظر
عن الأداء على المسرح الذي قمت
بإنشائه مؤخرًا.  يُدعى لطيف
وهذه القطعة تستكشف المسارات المختلفة التي
نواجهها لقد اخترت أه أنت تعرف
اسم الله لطيف بسبب هذا
النوع من الدقة التي يرشدنا بها
خلال الحياة ولذا فإن الكثير من
أعمالي الأخيرة تستخدم هذه الموضوعات العالمية
الموجودة  في الإسلام لأنني أعتقد أن
الناس من جميع الخلفيات الدينية يمكن أن
يستفيدوا من التعرف عليهم، انظروا إلى
أنفسكم،
وخلقوا مساحة للنساء المسلمات هنا
للالتقاء والاستمتاع بنوع فني
من المساعي كان ذا
قيمة فائقة لمجتمعنا
ولذا أعتقد أن
التمكين  أه النساء المسلمات على
وجه التحديد من خلال الرقص يأتي من
الحصول على رخصة للإبداع
للتعبير عن أنفسهن بطريقة تشعرهن
بالأمان
والرقص بالنسبة لي هو حقًا لغة
الروح، إنها لغة غير منطوقة
[موسيقى]